all right
let check that Al be
working so the check is that when I come
here I'm making
contact sliding
down not coming around
up
down you can hear the
wood okay try it
don't keep the parallel to the de
to move
hisap yes
hi
that's don't drop the
tip have to pick it up when we go
it's the right hand lowers versus the
left hand
lifting
classic that
tip there you go okay so now as you're
going that's that's that's what's
happening
here
this this
up to it around
it up to it
around
it put it together still take car me
[Applause]
so remember the first time I did it you
guys didn't notice the
slide okay so don't have so much
diction there it's
fluid like the wind hits around okay
right we did a pause already
okay two more
is
keep that tip up right hand
down yes Qui
weight the ability to run forward if
need
okay let's do
the so this these I adions where I make
contact and slide down something and go
around it it's still mid-range
grappling close range grapp is when I he
holds the Joe right and I'm sitting here
trying to crank this
but I do midrange
gra so in midrange grapping you have to
reach out and touch these
things I'm not going to wait
here not going to wait here for him to
hit me
so and where where do I reach out I
reach out in the space so he has to go
slow and we have to watch his tip
there his tips close to the line and
then it goes around to the
outside and then back down so it's
coming up
y
yin to Y so in the yin phas I'm going to
reach out for
it I'll show you it's ever so slight
here
so pay attention he made contact with
me and when he goes out I roll around
comes back in and I
go let
goary never my
you can see the energy this can go back
okay
try don't sit there and wait there's a
moment you can slightly
reach just the tip
less
good finish it don't freak out okay you
have a job to do that he was freaking
out too you just go you you have the
atttention of that uh pre-assault attack
you get it and you're like this I'm
going you're not going to stop that
because the guy did did that do you
understand so you you feel his sword
going W you're going to smash through it
okay don't let it freak you out that
it's touching you
go just do your move like the before
right
for
okay so each time in these sets these
sets aren't like
Keon in Keon we talked about how theuk
has a
prescription the grab let's say for some
sort of grab the spinal displacement and
then don't seek control
neither going for for n or trying to get
out of Nag's control neither of those
are right okay these are more like one
step
sparring so each time we add to it
you're working on your you're working on
your move he's working on the counter to
that move got it okay so it's not my job
unless the teacher would tell you hey
let's work together because we don't
know the technique we that sometimes but
we've been doing this part so I'm not
asking the Joe guy to do
anything I'm not telling them to stop
doing anything I'm telling the buling
guy how to do something for someone
who's doing that with
okay and so each time we add to it you
get to work on that one basic on that
side of the FL how to do it how to use
the counter against the counter okay
all right if I need to if I need
cooperation I'll tell you
okay all right so I'm doing that same
thing going like
that I I'm going to come around and here
so we'll go slow so you can see it Kitty
guys reach absorb the M out move into
the m so at hand High my shoulder
Hand high for my uh sorry shoulder high
for my hands I should be hitting
men no too
[Music]
close all right
guys start out slow teacher comeand okay
go
s the back of the head down the center
line
yes a little
slower and more
if I have any if he presses down on my
shoulders at all I can't do the move so
slower still got
you you feel it going around you okay
try it again move to the middle please
there you
go even slow ad
don't hit them one
more still getting you Swit
R so this time we're not going to let go
the
s okay we only get that one move not not
three
steps come from the back of your head
because you're going to slice him down
to his tailbone
okay
DET contact
early the
chest so the back foot is starting to
move starts to drop front foot comes out
boom
slow fo moves
stay
slow his weapon should hit
air but I don't lose contact
if you point your tip down more when you
come up it won't feel his Joe
way go under your sword go under your
sword when you move go under your sword
not your sword over your
head your target is high but your mind's
not high and your stance is not high
all right let
we got to get
in so I would take this foot and come
forward versus
out good that was
good same thing don't come back
[Music]
up there's still some
pressure right there that your tip lower
even more angle and going lower
yourself that and then bring it around
the back of your body
all right let's
watch so we already know don't move
don't fight with your
arms okay you move your
body
so when I'm going here no no no no no no
no don't move your hands to the left
just like okay he's come in here take
what I'm going to do is keep my hands on
my Center my hands go up my center and I
move my
body see step under my
sword don't come
around fade
why so in order to do
this
if right here and I cut I allow for too
straight an angle okay and I'm trying to
pull it
up it'll tend to hit you because rewind
the
film this
has another rotation coming back and it
tends to go
so I want to keep my sword at a 45°
angle here but it's heavy you see you
feel it he got some of me so I have to
lower
myself as I do all
that not
this not this
hit hit there's a window where it goes
around
you okay and you have to fit in that
window okay
five back to
threes I had to lower my hands came up
my Center I had to get underneath I had
to move forward so that the sword can go
around
me and not me moving the sword around
I lower to go under the sword I move
forward so the sword goes around
me
yes now as you can see when you finish
your AOS he's cutting you too
okay all right work on that and we'll
work on
that you have to go under your hands and
forward of it coming behind you
the slightest little bite is going to
have have
that let it come around
got to feel the we're going so slow that
it's not Amplified you
[Music]
better is any amplification
disappear see this
hits I'll do the lift
again that little
LIF and you can hear the w
[Music]
okay read that set
all right we go keeping
on what you will feel is the void that
void feeling when you feel it you have
to stop you you've lost the the Y
okay when you keep feeling the
resistance I would keep going that thing
like okay but when you feel the void it
look completely void it'll feel like and
you you respond to that and you get the
hell out of there
where do you
go you face
him up the circle
okay sword cut kept going you
miss foot's pointed at him and you're on
the back foot okay you don't have to be
a Million Miles Away in fact you'll find
that hard if you are really committing
on this shot you got to go forward okay
very hard to reverse your energy so
don't ask for a lot just go like whoa
okay that was going to
miss good okay try
not running away just not getting
cut and keep looking at
him don't come up stay down
see how close you can
get stay right out of leg
range right out of Sword
range make sure you're oriented at him
your feet are underneath your
hips we don't know what angle we're
going to move at so be as neutral as
possible
try not to go backwards move up to
Circle and cut where he was not where
you know he's going to go cuz your cut
should have been done by that time
right fix the footwork go slower
Ronan we going to stay
slow good that's
it good
tempo for
too many
steps don't go backwards move up to the
circle
and we have to stay out
of okay
so I'm
sorry so I one and I'm going to have
that weapon pointed at
him the right hand stays exactly where
the power line is one f with away
okay
try slower than we we were doing it
smoother it's
new what this is doing is helping me not
move into close range grappling
nice and
slow and
and again only two steps one
two we're going to go really
slow slow there
slower that's it
okay that was the right time to do it
get out
okay finish your
move lower
calmer don't be so close there you go
slow smooth and
calm and then
look this
more
presents okay all right
I do that
move come up
here just wind it up this is the move
you
did
right at the
beginning it's just
bigger
find okay we're going to do in stages
he'll stop at men I'll
move
one I'm going to come
around now parallel to the
deck
one he stops one two
good
around parall to the deck
right hand stays on your power line on
the Jung
ding underneath you now go forward with
it okay let's try slow and mechanical
like that andic
slide on the
buen slide down the boat okay
okay don't point the tip down
okay to point the tip down you got
to lift the power hand the power hand is
the back hand you get it you think you
think you're pushing the tip down but
you're lifting the power hand you don't
want to lift the power hand power hand
boom throws it all the way down okay one
more okay cycle through
men men men Reach
Out gather
it and take cuz when we hit that thing
it's going to go flying down and to the
left so stay non-resistant to the sword
to the
joke slow
down
it good don't get pinned on your feet or
your shoulders or your
[Music]
hands men
men leave your sword up at head level
till he
moves stay up there good come cut yep
make contact
Chris now
good and you changed the first move for
no apparent reason Chris
don't get so close that he just reaches
out and mix your fingers
okay come
up good slow down and bring it to the
top of your head by Rolling it into
place you got to go way slower and way
smoother
okay move first move
first yep and now just roll it till it's
on the top of your head your right
hand's on the top of your head roll your
wrist more even more yes okay and then
come around the contention Point don't
move into him stay at your advantage
slide down the weapon drop the right
hand not the
tip good
slower and
smoother move up and out
range roll it to the top of your head
your
head come around it whoops try it again
don't move his weapon move the right
hand and you'll come around don't move
his
weapon this is one of those things
that's hard to imagine this things like
iido iido uses uh it's like this this
technique here you're like the only way
I get to go back is to do that see but
this
one
um or this morning like the only way I
can get him to turn is that I turn me or
the x pattern I'm going to trace the x
pattern with my body and no no no that I
made the pattern the pattern manifest
but never draw the pattern okay so his
sword
uh is going to go down when I do this
move and down to the left you see but I
didn't move my weapon to the
left my weapon is literally coming down
this
side that's what it's doing
so our drill here
embryonically is I know that's my
movement and I'm going to lower my
height so I can get and keep contact
no no without pushing it come around the
other side down the other
side down the side
[Music]
I don't want to move into that because
his sword is going to the left control
you don't want to move into that it's
going you have to stay out of range and
let that
go so I'm out of range
I got
[Music]
C okay try it again
right rotating cross
slow smooth and calmly we have no chance
of non
contesting the closer your right hand is
to your spine the heavier that tip
careful not to reach out
no moved it to the to your right
the more we move it to the right the
less drop we're going to have cuz it's
not vertically down and the less
vertical drop we have the less pin we
have on the feet the more mobile he
remains the more likely he's going to
defend my ski followup if I pin his feet
Boom by the time he unpins it I've
already skewed it okay so there's a
marshal reason not just a philosophical
yinong non- contestation reason to not
move it to the right leave it there and
the more vertically down your atos is
the more martially pinning you're going
to have okay keep going slow training
calm
training make the wood
noises make the wood
noise you don't you don't lower your
sword he lowers your sword you don't
resist him lowering your sword
that's the Emi rule
right take off all pull on your shoulder
I think your step on your left foot
going out to lower your Center is
leaving your shoulder
pushable
you're not rolling that at all
D ad
getting checked there then let's slow
that
down lighten the pressure don't take
advantage of the lighter
pressure keep your hands on the weapon
keep going we'll keep going
confusing new chem we're countering
now do they K got the returning
cut not the absorption the absorption is
within the returning cut
come down
don't point it
down don't move your feet leave them
more
there top of your head not not someone
else's head there you
go don't move your feet you stepping out
with your left foot
now move it to the right we're going to
work on these things over and over and
over all right let's get to work
move close to
the calal
in
R kicking
right slow and smooth and calm one slow
tempo yes that was a Tempo
change
yes roll a little
more and then just a
game wait vertical first no don't move
my weapon you can't move my weapon you
cannot move my weight so I let me let me
hold your joke okay you're going to
start to drop your right hand so don't
move it so that it comes to the other
side don't move it you're moving it go
around it good now it drops
boom and don't point the ti down so that
I don't step on it
on smooth
Tempo good smooth Tempo good
whoops make a cross at
top there don't move it you're fine
you're fine at the cross then come
straight down don't drop the
ti let me let me uh show
this at this I call this embryonic
because this is not the actual timing of
the of the stri okay the we show
the that's the actual time so he he I
don't block it I attack the is what's
happening okay but to learn the geometry
that I want is it's right here so you
haven't experienced this already um
where you
miss you see and the reason that we
missed is that I don't have the angle of
what we call an angle incidence I
establish the
cross and now there's no way I'm going
to miss so I make contact here
not over here that's a very small thing
to hit you see so I I go perpendicular
to the weapon system then I can always
hit so there's a perpendicular moment in
all of these techniques so perpendicular
then the
ru and he
goes I come
here and I am going to go around this
there it is okay
drop so we're going to look for that
cross go around it
down
cross down
it okay let's try that
your right hand is going to have to
move a little to the
left can't go from here back here it's
going to go this
way then from there it goes down right
okay let's
try for this Dr hold your sword out
there until they move your hands which
is the right
change temp all
right okay we're going to make that
cross wait don't move it try not to move
it Just a Little Joe
game okay stay there now don't move it
just come down it boom underneath
you change Tempo Tempo is revealing of
the Mind the mind is going in and out
and so I'm late you feel late so you go
fast you're doing fine smooth breathing
relax
cross down try not to move it over it'll
happen on
cross down straight down straight down
don't worry what's going to happen you
just bring your like
that that's
it okay yeah almost
yourside okay however you think about it
if you pay attention it's right down my
Center
okay a little close
good are you moving me and you're a
little closer let's Mo back
for okay back up top around it straight
down move me ever so slightly leave it
there in space go around it you move it
right there at the
end yes there it is go down and you see
you're at my spot okay
that's where you move
[Music]
okay all
right you have to be careful this
two
okay when I'm here like this I can't
keep dropping in the
perpendicular so I keep dropping i' come
off if he keeps cutting it's too
low I only
drop to go around this
part as if this is happening you
see I don't want this whole transition
to happen somewhere down here so when
it's there in
space I have if I don't
lower I there's pressure right going
this way so I lower to take that lateral
pressure off but it's high when I do
it let your sort of be relaxed and it
will follow you
down and it's
too low you
see I lower to go around
it I'm taking my left hand so you can
tell I'm not
driving I just go around it and then I
let it fall
so if you watch I know I'm lowering but
if you watch where I am I'm in the cross
the cross is up high Cross
High okay so try to TOS as high as you
can
okay we
yep that's fine
little close
not to move me
go St
y you're
fine so have this little urge for then
you catch yourself okay let go of the
urge and don't worry about catch
so that's why it's important that you're
out of that sword range because you
don't want to take it into you okay and
also like
my my
uh my overall
strategy he has a major advantage
because of the length of his
okay so my overall strategy is always
got to be close close as much as
possible and at least
generate the Dilemma of closing okay
that I can try other long longer range
things okay that might surprise him
after he's used to and having to feel
like he def has to defend Clos so if you
look at the first move the first move is
the shorter we
trying to get inside this weapon his
defense is get outside of that weapon
can go back to
okay so my as we're going and I'm trying
this I would be trying this kind of
stuff if he moved inside the
circle then I would be thinking
this okay has to
where my advantage outside the sword
which is outside the leg okay and then
if you stay outside the sword you can
attack this sword from the inside as if
you're on the outside it does not going
to hit you he goes
boom okay that's what we're trying to do
back to
threes make sure you're not too close
you would have got kicked before you
defended that
come up underneath
perpendicular that's
it don't move it
yes smooth one
timing yes one timing all the way
through
one timeing each rep
two got it guys not two slow one fast
it's one timing
okay you guys will only do reps of two
before you
change one timeing
perpendicular
underneath let's not start over we
already got
there don't move it to the right
just come
down come down the other
side it's still being moved to the
right L as pure a vertical drop as
possible
yes slow and
smooth Reach Out
Reach Out
men don't change Tempo
yes he doesn't have to feel like he has
to protect his hands
that's better and then you will let him
move your
foren slow and smooth slow and smooth
M foot weight
still moving it to the
right do your cross fire come straight
down the
hands don't move the sword out of the
way don't pay what's going to
happen straight down sort Cross
High straight down
down
better better
yes okay we have to look at some I know
I
swear there a lot of things you can
do with grounding mechanics that she
cannot do with exal
mechanics to the extrem well I've
demonstrated several things this week on
one but that's just
stupid okay you need a base it's got to
be low okay and there's got to be
distance between your feet you
see for external
okay um because I
am like this at the B and I
am not like
this okay and what this affords me to do
is I have all my weight over what I'm
doing and not on the side of what I'm
doing
okay so um get your
joke and again it'll be hard for me
doesn't really know how to do these
things so
position
okay and if I wanted to try to lift this
thing it's not going to be
possible if
he squats to the side of it even if the
hand is you can move it back a little
even if it looks like it's close but
he's not over
it then it's not as heavy okay so what
you're going to do in this drill we can
do it with
that okay is boom you're going to finish
and then your partner will come out and
lift
up straight up the middle of the Joe
okay that's our girl now go okay and
you'll try to get your weight over that
spot I'm going to tell you we're not
pinned like the externalist will think
we're pinned we're heavy as and
we're going to be every bit as mobile
okay so now we're just I'm just
answering the question are we heavier
I'll then answer are we mobile okay so
let's
go and you're lifting straight up the
Joe between the two hands
you do the whole four top Yeah from the
top so we get more
reps nice and smooth make sure we're out
of
range
down
good and he's just going to lift
up okay
get your weight with the intention that
you're not don't let him lift that thing
up
okay I'll let you reposition after the
Joe if you want after you do the strike
if you want reposition
okay he's not going to move you do it
okay now make your that middle part of
the Joe as heavy as you possibly can
okay so how about we lift our butt a
little bit more and try to get more
weight over forward on top of the Jae
just a little more you're right you're
right there just a little more than you
are right now that was much more than
the than the first one here we go
again I don't care how you get there and
I'll let you move at the end
okay bend your knees more good and move
your weight over the top of that okay
and now he's going to try to lift be
strong on there in that part push down
on it with your
weight okay now we stay
there okay and he'll get that grip now
lower your butt
more not forward lower your butt more
don't hold it yet R don't hold it yet
okay
okay and your butt is lower now okay and
now he'll
lift and put your butt a little higher
and bend your knees a little more now
you're over the top and now he'll
lift okay guys see that got that
difference so the more lifting
resistance I can overcome the more
downward pressure I actually have okay
so watch now how I'm actually doing that
same
position there we go okay from here I'm
going to withdraw and
deep the sword will move to the other
side so the right rib cage is open and
you stab that respiratory
Meridian boom
boom Tiner pcture his
lungs again we'll go slow
okay try take your chemy so you don't
get bruised okay go don't run from
it don't get punctured by
it nice and slow and smooth
withdraw the
Joe and enter EDI Left Foot Right
Foot okay
where
your finish up move
[Applause]
good he'll he'll he'll do
it just let your sword go this way so
this six is exposed we're try we're
really slow training right now so we
don't have all the uh
momentum
okay good and he'll move
you for
h
it's not a
lightsaber you're not playing
pool you're not we're not playing
pool that would be
pool one more
go slow cuz you're not aware slow let
your mind come in
withdraw so you're going to you're going
to do
pull you're going to you're going to
pull Q through your circle hand and tag
him with a sharp tag
I have to withdraw the I'm on his weapon
I don't want him sticking to me you see
so I withdraw the Joe it's going to come
out
okay out
right okay back down not
here clear
weapon out where do you think on your
Center yeah on here home
body
okay ow
you got to time
it back
in that would be
bicep for
slow down here go down down y okay now
really slow down draw the Joel clear it
that's all you need doesn't have you
don't want to come all the way back I
just want to off yeah okay and then
you're going to bring it back to the
center okay
boom and now you do your body don't let
it come behind you keep it right
underneath and your body hits that's it
so let's go back get in that
position good you cleared his weapon
clear you're going to slide it through
that's it and then you bring it to your
power line the Jong ding right there
okay and then you use your
stance your footwork and your stance
work that's what moves me
go let's come
on good so look how you had to stay on
that line the other times you're ruding
you're taking that back foot and going
up the circle okay all right try it
again
[Music]
back to Jing and then your body hits on
the throwing
architecture so go back to the first
drill that we
did don't move your arms move your
arms
move
same this is what I said when you're
using your
bicep Boom the up you're
here you were here then you went to here
that's
set
here okay you hold it in that
position this is your whole body sitting
here okay try it again on the straight
line shifting to the front young
position back foot stays ground it back
foot is pushing
pushed don't move your arms at the
end if you want to go back further take
a big
step push more on the back
foot clear
J ding joust don't
[Music]
push oh this it's old habits but you're
aware at least you know right you you
know like ah push okay there's a whole
bunch of people out there that think
that's the way to go cuz no one ever
stayed still like I did and went nowhere
okay so you're you're ahead of the game
keep going we'll give it to you
again if we slow down we can bring more
of our processing mind
in
nice and now we're going to slow down
come to the Jing line hold position
parallel that Joe parallel the Joe good
and you just hold that and you move your
horse that's
it that's
it okay cycle
through Chris you doing it hi
[Music]
okay that's it
slide it through your
hand got it then slide it back to
there slow down so you can think
go down okay slide through the hand
slide back through the no slide back
through the hand to Jong D and then grab
it don't shove it with your hand
if you're going faster than I'm talking
you're it's too fast for you
obviously withraw through the
left push hold
boom okay now what Ronan is doing is
once you start going that way then you
can follow
okay but you can't hit in the cork screw
the cork screw comes after you've
displaced it okay all right thank each
other